let's go to christian from california
christian welcome
christian from california welcome
can you hear me okay david yes i can
um so i'm actually calling you from the
campus of my my
uh school right now and i'm just
wondering what
exactly do you think is
you know how biden just forgave some
student loan debt what what do you see
as like the long-term solution to like
how college is becoming more and more
unaffordable the long-term solution is
it's not going to be just for giving
some debt the long-term solution is
going to be something has to put
some combination
of downward pressure on the educational
costs
and upward pressure on wages
so that they are in line
in a way that makes a lot more sense and
unfortunately i don't really see a clear
path to that right now i do think free
community college for two years for an
associate's degree would do some of it
so
if people had the option
of paying for four years at an expensive
school
or doing your first two years for free
at community college and then only doing
two years at the expense of four-year
school your junior and senior year to
finish out your four-year degree
i think that that would put significant
downward pressure on what the four-year
schools are able to charge for example
um i know this one isn't popular with a
lot of people but if it were a little
more difficult to just get a student
loan to cover your entire education now
by more difficult i i mean
maybe it has to be tied to
something that makes it more in line
with the expected wages for that degree
or so i don't know it's difficult that
might put downward pressure on education
costs but it's very difficult but i i
don't believe the solution
is for giving a little bit of debt here
and there or even forgiving all of it
because those are basically licenses for
colleges to charge whatever the hell
they want
wasn't it was it always sort of this
easy i mean like i don't know how long
federal student loans have been around
but have they always been so accessible
to like just about anyone who wants to i
mean sign up for one no but they also
weren't as in demand because there was a
time during which
you could kind of like work your way
through college the the idea of that is
kind of absurd at this point in time so
they've become more accessible as
they've become more in demand so it's
it's been both
right all right i have a patient at a
clinic i work at who says she went to
berkeley in the 60s and was able to pay
for it working part-time which is insane
to think of now tom hartman who's a talk
radio host on on the left he talks about
how his wife louise i believe it's that
she was able to basically waitress
through college and pay for it and come
out with i think it's almost no debt
wow that's that's crazy to think about
all right david thank you so much for
your time and taking my call my pleasure
thank you so much for the question yeah
it's it listen the student loan debt
forgiveness alone is not the solution to
the problem that's uh that's for damn
sure